I just can't view American women as is
subordinate I think it's a complicated
mix of for men and women of benefits and
burdens I don't think women are
oppressed as women well here we are on
this week's Sunday special with
christina hoff sommers you know her from
the femme splinters and also she is the
factual feminist she's over at American
Enterprise Institute we are gonna get
into all manners various and sundry but
first let's talk about the end of your
life you're going to die and that means
that you need life insurance life
insurance is really important it's also
really confusing no wonder four out of
ten people don't have it maybe you're
one of those people but if anything were
to happen to you if you were to plotz
it's important that your loved ones are
taken care of besides
life insurance rates are the lowest that
they've been in 20 years and the best
time to buy is right now the best place
to buy is policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find that best policy
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over
twenty billion dollars in coverage they
don't just make life insurance ease they
also do disability insurance and
renter's insurance health insurance all
sorts of insurance if you care about it
they can cover it so if you've been
putting off getting life insurance
there's no reason to do so any longer
because you put it off too long you're
gonna be dead then this can be too late
go to policy genius com get your quotes
apply in minutes it is that easy do it
right now and you should that rates are
their lowest in 20 years policy
genius.com
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance again policy genius calm well
christina hoff sommers thanks so much
for stopping by really appreciate it oh
i'm so happy to be here it uses me with
happiness cuz you're a happy person so
let's talk a little bit about your
background so for folks who don't know
christina hoff sommers she's the
feminist that feminists loved hate
because you actually say factual things
about males and females and sex
differences and and the hot topics today
we'll get to all those hot topics but
first let's talk about how you got where
you are politically because you weren't
always conservative in fact in some
areas you still don't consider yourself
a conservative so how did you go from
being kind of just an academic professor
to being one of the most well-known foes
of the of the modern feminist movement
well I first of all I was brought up in
LA not far from here I went to
university high school and I guess in
Brentwood and
I was very left-wing and especially in
high school I read the Communist
Manifesto and it all made sense it seems
so right of course to each according to
his need from each according to his
ability it was just kindness and so I
was quite carried away with that for a
while and then I don't know in college I
ever met I remain not a Marxist but just
my default mode was always liberal my
parents very very liberal bordering on
Communists but then in 1988 I was a
professor a college professor and I was
invited to go on semester at sea it's a
ship that goes around the world and it's
a university at sea and so somehow I got
on this thing and I was teaching and I
guess I was I'd been teaching maybe for
10 years or something but I had never
sat in my fellow professor's courses
before and so this ship was about 500
undergrads mostly conservatives as far
as I could tell from USC SMU pretty
wealthy you know mom and dad could
afford to send jr. on a trip around the
world and the professor's were socialist
to Marxist
and so I started to bicker with them and
in this course we had called core and I
suddenly and then suddenly at the end of
the trip this older professor was very
left-wing warned me you better be
careful you're gonna end up being just
like Jean Kirkpatrick and I didn't know
she was I looked her up and thought I
think I like her maybe I am and she was
at AEI and I ended up at AEI but anyway
it was kind of accidental I think if I
hadn't got on that ship I might not have
known what was going on in other
people's courses okay so what happened
to academia so even that can even for a
long time have you seen active changes
in the way that academia has operated
since the 80s or do you think that it's
been pretty consistent it's just more
well known because of social media now
in terms of the sort of radical leftist
dominance even in in some of the hard
sciences in terms of shutting down
debate and an investigation into
knowledge it's gotten worse and worse
and here's why it used to be the
universities always you know stret tends
to be liberal however a lot there's a
lot of radicals that came out of the 70s
late 60s 70s for various reasons went
into the universities it was the one
institution that you could take your
radical politics and find a home there
and they did they were more radical than
the liberal professors who hired them
might have believed in intellectual
diversity so maybe they would have
allowed some conservatives and moderates
and had some radicals the radicals
didn't think the same way so as the
older scholars retired and the young
radicals gained a foothold in in many
departments I mean certainly women's
studies they were always there and the
various you know ethnic studies but even
in political science departments history
to her certainly English departments
there they would start hiring their own
and and a limit you know just not invite
anyone else to come to the campus so you
had certain departments become
like-minded people like-minded thinkers
and they did not present the other side
respectfully and they didn't want to
have candidates come in if you came in
and appeared to be conservative or even
moderate you wouldn't get hired so it's
so the professor's have become more
radical and I also think if you look at
the schools of Ed people don't think
about schools of Ed what's the
curriculum there it's it's very
left-wing
and so we have a lot of teachers who are
trained in liberal left orthodoxy going
into our junior high schools and high
schools so so you have had a
transformation of the educational system
so you call yourself a factual feminist
how do you define feminism because
obviously a lot of feminists would
accuse you of not being a feminist
because you don't agree the sort of
prevailing left-wing trends inside
feminism so what do you think true
feminism is and then how is it being
abused the trans determine expanded
abused by some of the folks on the left
well I think a true feminist is an
equity feminist and that's just someone
who believes he wants for women what she
wants her ever
I mean dignity equality opportunity
liberty and equity feminism has been a
great American success story I mean if
you look at the progress women have made
and just open you know doors have opened
and women wherever women wanted to go
they've gone they were there now more
women than men in college and in certain
disciplines in psychology veterinary
medicine these used to be overwhelmingly
male and now women are taking over in
many of the social sciences where women
want to go they they went there they've
achieved parity with men are approaching
parity in law school and medical school
so there's been enormous change to which
and I credit equity feminism just
equality feminism where you just don't
have arbitrary barriers against women
but there's another school of feminism
entirely that is not part of this kind
of classical liberal tradition of
greater opportunities for people this is
what I have called gender feminism
because they believe in what they call
the sex gender system and that women are
not merely held back by old-fashioned
laws or customs it's not enough to
change the society the entire system
must be taken down that you know and and
so it's a much more radical approach and
they they think of American women as an
oppressed class of people and and when
and so after I was on that ship and I
had there was some radical feminists
there too I wrote a piece about what I
experienced on that ship called
professor at sea and I sent it to the
Atlantic and the editor Rupe and I'd
written about the feminist sonship who
were very colorful and extreme and you
know we were seeing the whole world and
and we've come into ports and the the
students could go and see some of the
glories of civilization the Alhambra you
know they could go to Seville and they
would take them to wedding stores to see
how the wedding industry oppressed
Spanish women and things like so I just
heard about this and Michael Curtis this
editor at the Atlantic said I can't
really use the piece that you wrote but
the way you talked about the
this is so different so interesting and
you're doing it as a feminist and he
said I'd like you to write about that
and that later became my book who stoled
feminism so in the book who stole
feminism I pointed out that there are
these two traditions and that one of
them is everyone should be every
contemporary American should be an
equity feminist and we have pretty good
data which shows they are most people
believe in equal pay for equal work and
they want their daughters and sons to
have the same opportunities so equity
feminism I believe that we owe most of
women's progress to that classical
liberal tradition that came in really
from the European enlightenment gender
feminism does not come out of the
European enlightenment as such it's more
of a Marxist tradition conflict theory
class struggle but in this case gender
struggle are now intersectional
struggles so I I just can't view
American women as subordinate I think
it's a complicated mix of for men and
women of benefits and burdens I don't
think women are oppressed as women well
why do you think gender feminism has
gained so much credence and credibility
American women are living the best lives
the women who ever lived in the history
of the world by a pretty large margin
why is it that this sort of toxic
feminism to use a good hijack attorney
hey why is it the dad has has gained so
much ground in the public discourse well
as I said it gained a foothold in the
Academy and particularly in women's
studies so it's sort of a one-party
system and if you are a dissident
feminist and you could be a feminist you
could be a scholar you can be a Laura
Kipnis or a Katie Roy feat Christina
summers it can be a poly mi but all of
us have been critical of aspects of
radical feminism then you become persona
non grata you become part of the problem
part of the systemic oppression of women
you've become an agent of the patriarchy
and they just call you names so you
don't get hired you're you're materials
aren't taught so students are we have
now you know going back 20 years
graduates in the more elite school the
more likely
in their gender studies you know they're
very adamantly teaching these these
rather extreme theories about women's
oppression and they use propaganda phony
statistics and so we have lots of young
people coming out becoming bloggers
becoming you know activists who've never
heard the other side they've read it in
their textbooks they've heard it look
that whole worldview was reinforced now
its truth they looked at the real world
it doesn't seem to match but it you know
it's not majority majority of students
don't become angry feminists but enough
to and now they're moving into the ends
of the society what do you think of the
idea that this is part and parcel of the
the hunger for a sense of victimology
that seems to be kind of crossing all
political boundaries it now applies to a
lot of people on all sides of the
political ally of folks who think
they're victims of foreign trade people
stealing their jobs you have people who
think that they're victims of an
overarching racist American system and
now you have women who again are living
in an extraordinarily privileged time by
any dimension by any measure and it was
opportunity rich women in history and
and then there and but they've had to
come up with some framework in which
they are victims how much of this do you
think is actually prosperity eating
itself is just a prosperous group of
people who have decided that they have
to maintain some sense of victimhood in
order to give them a sense of purpose in
the world it could be that it's a you
know I don't want to speculate too much
about their psychology because I'm just
not sure and there's and I even worry
about that
sometimes they worry like why aren't
there more dissident scholars like me
and it fills me with doubt I think maybe
there's something wrong with me maybe
maybe I am an agent of the patriarchy
and I'm not saying it and so then I try
to go back and read it and try it and
think okay I've missed something and
maybe maybe women really are oppressed
in some hidden way that I can't
appreciate now I've looked pretty
carefully as well as a lot along with a
lot of other people if things like the
wage gap in the glass ceiling and I just
can't help but see they're just other
reasonable explanations that have
nothing to do with discrimination but I
honestly try because it worries me that
so many of them are carried away with it
and you know why wouldn't there be more
people protesting and more scholar
they're not that many women scholars
that join me that's starting to change
now I think they've gotten so extreme
that maybe I will have more company but
anyway why do they believe it I mean
it's it's a conspiracy theory for smart
people and you know and the more
intelligent you are this is there's been
good you know psychological
documentation that just the more you can
talk yourself into a belief system and
maybe they you know had a bad experience
and they're projecting I don't know I
know you know Catherine MacKinnon who
was sort of the leader of the gender
feminist movement and you know she
thought that the patriarchal oppressive
system was so good it was almost perfect
so perfect that people couldn't even see
it it was invisible that's one of the
other things you know now that could be
a profound observation and some people
found it so not me I found it to be a
paranoid conspiracy theory about reality
that can't be falsified it can't test it
as soon as you question it that just
shows your part of the problem you know
but Catherine MacKinnon she did not win
in the beginning when she first came on
the scene and the New York Times was
covering academia and New York magazine
and LA Times my side was winning we won
in the court of public opinion can the
Oh Polly uh you know was certain she was
on covers and things we just we won the
argument
they won the assistant professorship and
that mattered more so let's go through
some of the myths that have been pervade
by the modern feminist movement because
you spend an awful lot of time doing
that but first let's talk about your
online security so whether you are in a
cafe or hotel we often rely on public
Wi-Fi to use the internet on the go but
something as simple as paying your bills
online from the Starbucks can actually
leave your data exposed a hacker could
easily intercept your information you
can steal passwords credit card numbers
personal details it's not just hackers
government agencies like the NSA well
they've got a lot of that information
too you don't really know how they're
using it so what can you do to defend
yourself well the software that I use to
protect my online activity from spies
and data thieves is expressvpn
expressvpn has easy to use apps they run
seamlessly in the background of my
computer phone and tablet an express VPN
secures an anonymized
browsing by encrypting your data hiding
your public IP address using expressvpn
I can safely surf on public Wi-Fi
without being snooped on or having my
personal data stolen for the best
protection you should use Express VPN
every time you go online and here's the
nice thing expressvpn cost less than
seven bucks a month it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
try it and see if you like it so take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
for free go to expressvpn comm slash man
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash pen for 3
months free with a one-year package get
expressvpn secure your internet right
now is it expressvpn comm slash Ben to
learn more ok so let's go back to these
myths so myth number one the wage gap
which you mentioned this is used by
virtually every feminist scholar to
suggest that America has some sort of
superstructure of patriarchy what are
the real facts about the wage gap does
it exist and if so to what extent there
is a gap of about 20 cents if you look
at all men and all women working full
time you will find this gap however it
doesn't take into account relevant
factors that affair just what did you
major in in college what profession are
you in how many hours do you work per
week when you do these controls the wage
gap begins to narrow and in some studies
it vanishes so if you look at majors
college majors you will make more money
on average if you go into I don't know
petroleum engineering or naval
architecture or metallurgy apparently
make money and for the PhD in metallurgy
but if you go into early childhood
education Social Work or women's studies
met not as much so that counts and oh
you know then we look well who majors in
petroleum engineering it's mostly men
and who majors in early childhood
education mostly women so that is not
you know you have to take into account
these relevant factors and what I see in
study after study is they either don't
do it
or they play a little game like the
American Association of University Women
they will say oh yes it's true when you
take relevant you know factors into
control it narrows but there's still a
gap and then they insist but of you know
they'll say 12
sir 15 cents but but they don't take all
of the relevant factors because there
probably took 20 or 25 things I mean
look at things like the danger of a job
if you look at the the death gap it's
almost all men I think it's 94 percent
of fatalities in the workplace our men
Labor Department data and every year you
know so we've got about 5,000 people who
died in the workplace almost all men so
that's another thing they never look at
the workplace as a totality what jobs
are people doing and most of the gritty
dangerous jobs you know have you've seen
a woman like as a roofer or if you're in
a high-rise building and there's some
guy out there it's always a guy rushing
the windows and you know so there's a
you do get a pay premium for a danger
you do get a pay premium for working odd
hours or strange hours now when I debate
them they'll say yes okay fine you're
right but it's still discrimination
because why is it that men take those
jobs and women take their jobs and why
are women's jobs degraded and so forth
well that's an interesting question but
they've now changed the focus of the
argument because we're not talking about
equal pay for equal work we're now
talking about they sort of want
comparable pay for similar work or you
know or they want the society to you
know do something about the fact that
women do I mean the main reason women
earn less is that when women have kids
they tend to withdraw or you know work
less and when men have kids they work
more so they'll say well why is that
that's sexism well again we're no longer
talking about employers and we're no
while are we talking about you know a
wage gap that is because some evil
employers are deliberately paying men
more it's they change the ground but
even when you go there and ask why do
people do what they do and you know is
it a sex role sort of thing that's a
different set of arguments but even
their their arguments are not persuasive
because if I look at the patriarchy and
say okay that's my hypothesis that we
were we do what we do
we've all been conditioned under
patriarchy and then I see the United
States is less patriarchal than it's
ever been women are constantly
encouraged to do all sorts of things in
schools little kids are encouraged to
play with all sorts of toys but the kids
insist the kids are the ones that you
know are jet you know they stereotyped
themselves and you even see the kinds of
play little girls with dolls the
feminists have been very upset by that
because they think that that conditions
them to be mothers and we should bond
little boys with dolls
well they've tried that and then the
little boys will you know turn them I've
been to conferences where there they'll
cry to say well yes I tried to use
bubbles and dolls and get the boys to
play and then they turn them into
torpedoes you know this and and by the
way that the gender feminists don't like
it when I bring up you know any of us
bring up those examples because they
still think it's conditioning it's good
well maybe it was conditioning that made
them gender feminists I mean then we get
into an argument free will and
determinism and we changed the ground
again into this meta in an interesting
argument about ultimate freedom of
self-determination but I think that we
have to at this point credit women with
agency when they choose what they're
gonna major in when they choose the
field if they want to stay home with
kids then I think that it's Mattern
izing to suggest that they aren't
responsible for their own lives and this
is one of the funniest things about
these particular statistics you look at
nations like Norway which have tried to
forcibly disabuse people of the
patriarchy and in some of those nations
there's a much larger pay gap than there
is in some of the developing nations
where women are actually forced to work
jobs that they don't want to it turns
out that when women are prosperous it
would very often less like to work those
jobs where they're dealing with heavy
equipment and not being able to be home
with their kids
well you just yeah the end people have
done surveys on preferences like what
would you like what would be your ideal
situation and over and over again you
find the following and this was
Catherine Hakim at the London formally
at the London School of Economics the
Pew Research Center has found that if
you ask women in the United States about
20% want to work full-time they want to
be high-powered careers that's a
number-one priority
20 percent would like to be full-time
stay-at-home mothers they do not wish to
be in the workplace and they will not be
there unless something no misfortune and
they have to and then 60% are called
adapters they they are women who want
want to work part-time when they have
little kids and then you know go back
and forth 60% and actually the 60%
behave a little more like the
stay-at-home moms and their preferences
and choices so you have 20 percent of
women who do want what you know the AAUW
and the MS foundation and now what
they're pushing they do a good job
pushing for the interests of that 20
percent of careerists but what if most
women aren't like that and shouldn't
that count and they will never say it
counts because they will think that
their preferences were shaped by patreon
right I mean if they're honest about
their like Betty Ford and they actually
look for compulsion
of itself is reinstituting the paper
that was similar before sorry you're
right
yeah maybe freed and if everyday was not
consistent but I I read I've reviewed
both of their books recently and found a
lot that I liked hello Simone de
Beauvoir was kind of she was actually
onon feta means and not sleeping
chain-smoking and she rich just went
into the bibliothèque nationale and
wrote everything everything you know
it's a manic I think anyway but she did
she did very harsh things to say about
motherhood but she certainly did not
have harsh things to say about love
affairs and her you know she frustrated
the feminist by saying you know the most
important thing in her life was
jean-paul Sartre and well why do you
think it is that the feminist movement
has decided to obliterate sex
differences because seems like that's
what it comes down to is that a lot of
this is preference based I mean if you
go back to biology itself I mean there
are studies of rhesus monkeys that show
that female rhesus monkeys prefer dolls
and male rhesus monkeys prefer weapons
like this right this is this is deeply
embedded in evolutionary biology because
it was the job of females typically to
have babies and then raise them and it
was the job of men to go out and protect
the mother so that they could raise the
babies because otherwise everybody would
die no this is pretty deeply about it
when did it become the the mission of
the feminist movement to say that there
is something fundamentally wrong if
women and men have separate preferences
because it seems like this has infused
so much of our conversation now about
men and women well I think they did it
for a few reasons one is there was a
time where any woman who defied the
stereotypes of femininity let's go back
in 30s and 40s 50s then she for her
these were it was you know a stall to
fiying conformity was it what was
enforced so I think initially that you
know feminists just wanted to break down
these stereotypes because maybe as many
as 20% of women did not embody them now
I think that's fine and that's what I
feminism is but equity feminism's are
also about freedom that what you you
take down the barriers but then women
should be allowed to do be who they are
and those of us who embody traditional
stereotypes and that's just who we are
and we would prefer to look workless
when we have kids or we prefer to go
into you know my field of in philosophy
I studied
I got my PhD and my dissertation was in
the area of ethics and that's just a
field you will find more women in
philosophy doing esthetics and ethics
then say philosophy of mathematics it's
more men so those were the choices that
I make and why isn't why as that
problematized you know you take down the
barriers and then you see what people do
and you do the best you can in your
educational system and parenting and I
think we do I think a lot of us of our
child I mean I have two boys who majored
in English I tried to talk them out of
it and but they were defying the
stereotype of you know I told them they
should major in engineering yeah and my
wife obviously is famously a doctor so
she's in the stem ya field and my
daughter is totally into it she walks
around the house saying that her brother
is going to be a radio host like daddy
and she is going to be in the sciences
like mommy yeah so I obviously agree
with the basic idea that in America
pretty much everybody is raising their
kids or at least a huge majority of
people are raising their kids to
basically do what they want to do and if
your kid wants to if your daughter wants
to be a scientist I don't see a lot of
fathers who are standing in the doorway
like John Lithgow in Footloose saying
you're not allowed to go study chemistry
now feminists on that they they had
these phony ads I think they ran them in
the Super Bowl one year when it went
kind of feminist and you know they have
a dad saying Oh put that away you know
you you know and give her a doll and she
wanted to play with her microscope you
know as if that happens very often but
anyway that that was one reason one is
that I think that they wanted to
liberate people that were forced into
the rule and then they didn't realize
that that might not be liberating for
everybody you want to liberate the
people that don't like it not not the
not human nature as we experience it
there was a second reason is that
historically there have been a lot of
disparaging and false things said about
women that held women back so women you
know my field and philosophy is among
the worst few read Nietzsche or Kant and
it's endless just all sorts of you know
generalizations about the females the
fair sex and how you know we couldn't
didn't have the the stem
for a court of law and you know all
sorts of things so I think feminism just
a lot of women just developed a
tremendous intolerance for for
generalizations but again that what they
should have done is allowed that
currently like people define themselves
and that you will find that there is a
tendency for women you know to behave in
certain ways and to make have certain
preferences people made a lot of money
you know making television shows and
magazines for that market if you look at
you don't they don't say in most stores
now men's magazines women but you kind
of know if you go and the women's you
know typically there'll be children or
you know faces and men there's a lot of
stuff you know it'll be a race car the
cars and and it just you know it's a
again that's that what we see in the
vervet monkeys and the rhesus monkeys
the the little the male will go for the
gadget and the female for the doll now
it's not a hundred percent there are
little girls that are gonna go for the
gadget probably even with the monkeys
but there's also the norm and I think
it's the thing is yes it is intolerant
to force a kid who defies the stereotype
of his or her sex force them to conform
but it's also intolerant to to take a
gender conforming kid and force them to
do what they don't want to do and to
force a boy to play with the doll if he
doesn't want to and one of the things
that's been really fascinating to watch
is how the transgender movement has
turned all of this on its head because
the transgender movement has basically
now suggested that men and women being
as feminist claims exactly the same a
man can actually be a woman so long as
he claims that he's a woman and this has
led to a bizarre backlash from people
like to remain Grier who have said wait
hold on a second there is something
special about being a woman after all
and we're not just going to admit
biological men into our category because
they say they ought to be admitted to
that category well I I have yet to hear
a coherent explanation of I mean I'm
mark I'm more tolerant trans than you
are and mainly because for for one
reason at AEI one of the first trans
people that I met was Deirdre McCloskey
there's my favorite economist
philosopher I haven't seen her lately
but she
it was just so impressive and I just
read her book and her story and I think
there is a legitimate human rights issue
there however and I think she would
agree with that it's all been
politicized
and you have people that may not even be
trans but who are wannabes or pretend I
mean there's some and who you know or it
won't allow anything to be debated or
discussed and you're constantly getting
getting into fights and I people used to
attack me by saying Christina Hoff
Sommers and and Margaret Thatcher those
two female impersonators someone
criticized me as a female impersonator
and it happened on tumblr a few months
ago and they got called out for using
the phrase female impersonator and
acting as though that was a criticism
vindicated by that and just think I
don't ask you about some more of the
myths that have been pervade by sort of
the feminist culture but first let's
talk about the quality of your sleep
there's nobody on the planet like you so
why would you buy a generic mattress
built for somebody else helix sleep
builds a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete they using the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there's no more
guessing and no more confusion just go
to helix sleep calm slash been guest
because I have a guest take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they will match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for a couple's
helix can even split that mattress down
the middle and provide individual
support needs and feel preferences for
each side they have a ten year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free so you really have
nothing to lose right now helix is
offering up to one hundred and
twenty-five bucks off all mattress
orders again 125 bucks off at helix
sleep calm slash of been guess that's
helix sleep calm slash been guest for a
hundred and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order I have a helix sleep
mattress in my own home my wife and I
did the sleep quiz we got the mattress
we opened it up and inflated right in
front of us we pop sit on the bed frame
it's good to go it's so nice that my
sister got one for her wedding as well
helix sleep calm slash been guest and he
had a hundred twenty-five bucks off your
mattress order right now again helix
sleep calm slash at been guest back to
you some of the myths that are being
pervade so one of the big ones that
you've taken on is the myth that America
has a deep-seated rape culture and I've
always been sort of bewildered as to
what exactly people mean when they say
rape culture like is there some vast
group of men out
or very pro rape that I've been missing
somehow and is there in fact some sort
of rape culture that's happening on
campuses what are the actual facts with
regard to the idea that America is in
the midst of a rape culture right now
well first of all for them a rape
culture is a society that is supportive
and encouraging of you know male
predation and they would say that that
just it's just ubiquitous and in films
and songs and and they will point to a
song like remember blurred lines no you
want yeah and so they take that line I
know you want it I know you want it and
then that's rape culture that's a man in
intimating that you know no matter what
she says it but then you know other
people would point out that there were a
lot of songs even songs I think even
Beyonce had a song that said that and so
it's never quite it doesn't you know I
try to find this culture because to me
it looks like we're a culture properly
so that is that despises rapists there I
mean there they're there with murderers
and child molesters rapists the low you
know lowest cycle of hell there's and
that's why it's very important to have
due process because it's such a serious
allegation because we have little
tolerance so I don't and and then look
at American society and you look at the
data and you see that all violent crime
has gone down
no one knows quite why but lots of
theories but rape and sexual assault
it's down except on the campus when they
do these studies that are flawed so they
have it's called advocacy research you
can prove anything if you rig the study
and how do you get one in four I'll tell
you how you go to a college campus and
you you administer maybe over online you
have a survey with some vaguely worded
questions and you ask them to a non
representative group of people and then
you know you can project into the whole
school or the whole town or the whole
world a rape epidemic now fortunately we
have very good statisticians in the
Justice Department the Bureau of Justice
Statistics they don't have an agenda
they just want to do good research and
they do an annual crime survey and for
one time I think was 2010 they they
actually pulled out the data on campus
and they found that they didn't in it
nothing like one in four they found more
like I think one in fifty three now that
is still high it's still a problem we've
got a binge drinking culture we've got
you know a lot of things going on and
could be improved and sexual harassment
and assault is a problem but it's not an
epidemic it's not like the worst crisis
I mean who would send a child who would
send a girl to Stanford or Berkeley you
know at Harvard if she you know and
people are lining up to get in there who
would send a child there if there was a
one in four chance that she was going to
be a victim of this serious sexual crime
so I didn't know people don't really
believe it but yet it's taught and it's
I think it's almost now a contagion of
hysteria and so you're getting more and
more young women are just so frightened
and and I look at like swathmore you
know the girls are frightened of these
swathmore these be it these elite
schools and then I mean now I'm not
saying there can't be boorish behavior
and the you know boys should be
gentlemen and ladies and the girls
should be ladies all of that but there's
no you can't find it it was manufactured
through a combination of twisted
theories about the patriarchy and
propaganda I mean they are in a gender
war in it in every war the first
casualty is truth this one is no
different it seems like the Boers have
been completely removed I mean the these
studies that I've seen word they're
suggesting numbers like one and four
basically they're conflating anything
from an unwanted touch to a full-on rape
and then saying that that is all part of
a rape epidemic happening on campus and
that's led to these essentially
Stalinist show trials that are happening
on campuses across the country with no
due process of law that seems to me a
lot more dangerous as an institution for
a college then the notion that the
college is somehow winking and nodding
at actual rape happening on his campus
absolutely and the sad thing is that
you're absolutely right now they have
these show trials and and they say oh
well women never make makeup
the accusations you have to believe
women you women do make up accusations
and and women do lie not because they
are women because they are human and
human beings will you know sometimes lie
especially about sex we just had a case
at Sacred Heart did you read about that
I miss this one oh my goodness there was
a trial and these two young men athletes
were thrown out you know they were
accused thrown off the team lost
scholarships it went on on finally in
court she admitted she made it up I
think it was sort of like the Jackie
case at University of Virginia that
rolling stone case she made it up
because she wanted her boyfriend wannabe
to feel sorry for either she had some
reason and they they allowed these young
men or it was one of them I saw making a
statement about what had had done to his
life
and it was it was horrifying you know he
just said you know it's it's it's
ruinous it's just psychologically really
a false accusation and and there's a
reason we have due process and this we
developed this this truth finding
apparatus it's the best we've got it's
not perfect but there's but what's much
worse is not to have it and now on
campuses they've dispensed with it in
many cases and you have people accused
and found guilty of very serious crimes
that you know there's no no jury would
have found them guilty there wasn't
evidence there's some case there's no
evidence in some cases there was
evidence that proved it didn't happen
and in these tribunals they wouldn't
accept it so I and I but I also feel
sorry for girls who have been victims
because now it's this crime has been
exaggerated all proportions so you know
at some schools if a boy walks by and
says nice legs you know a girl call that
it's in the feminist center that's a
mini rape you know they're appropriating
the language of predation and violence
for you know everyday things that go on
and so I think they're trivializing the
terrible thing that can happen it
because we do know that this can happen
on campus and the and then they have
procedures that nobody knows what's
going on or where it leads so it's not
helping anybody fortunately I think the
current Department of Education just
announced
they're going to change the requirements
for college and undo some of the the new
rules that were put in by the last
administration says someone who's been
accused of catcalling for asking a woman
to debate me publicly that's a I
definitely understand they kind of
broadening at the terminology what what
do you think is sort of a solution for
this because it seems like if you wanted
to create a recipe for a bunch of false
statistics and false positives in cases
of rape what you would first do is
suggest to men and women that there are
no differences between men and women
then you would tell them that to explore
their best selves that they should have
as much sex with as many partners as
possible and then you'd put them alone
as much as possible and then you would
set no standards for what actually rape
constitutes and finally you would say no
evidence is necessary in order for us to
convince you and you can do it all with
infinite amount of alcohol we're not
going to check right so it's always you
know it's it's alcohol saturated so it
seems like they've removed all the
traditional standards and then they've
decided to become prudes about the
results of a lot of this stuff it's
crazy you know there is an interesting
case that just happened at NYU avital
Ronell
is a professor of German literature and
complet she's a deconstructionist
feminists and a performance artist
so she goes into the class she has
costumes and she tells the students this
will not be classed as performance Adana
and you know some of them were love it
and a lot of them are probably bored or
horrified or whatever it doesn't matter
anyway she's a very very colorful
celebrity scholar within this little
niche world of performance scholarship
and she's and she's apparently gay well
now a gay guy nimrod reitman young he's
about he well i don't know what he is
now but he was maybe in his 20s when
this happened this was a few years ago
he's now accused her of sexual assault
sexual harassment and he's gay
she's a lesbian and and she's a leading
figure you know and sort of postmodern
deconstructionism so 50 leading feminist
scholars gathered around her you know
and wrote a letter excusing her and the
letter looked like the kind of excuse
people would give
for Raymore something you know like oh
it was a different time we really don't
know what was happening and then it
turns out she had an affair so she's a
great interpreter of the philosopher
Derrida yeah I think uh now it turns out
she had an affair with his son when the
son was 16 she was like a very bad
lesbian she's not even who knows is it
so anyway it's what it tells me is that
sex you know it's complicated and who
knows what went on with between these
two people was it appropriate not really
we have that she wrote a lot of texts
and things but I can understand the
people that love her that are on her
side you know I've seen this with young
men their families you know they see it
differently because they're looking at
it from his point of view and then she
now has her you know she has got her
side and the grad student has his side
net and the whole Academy's now and all
in a dither over this but to me maybe
the only way we could find out would be
in a court of law if and he is suing so
maybe interesting we will see if she
really wrote these things or said these
things but it proved to the whole
Academy the need for due process what
bothers me about is I wish these 50
scholars had noticed that this was
happening not just to their friend
avital Ronell professor of but but it's
been happening to young men and their
campus it's happened to a lot of male
professors where you're just run out of
town and assumed guilty because accused
I mean Laura Kipnis basically got
shellacked at Northwestern for simply
suggesting there'd be some sort of form
of due process for a male professor who
is accused of basically similar activity
and she was investigated this professor
was investigated for an article that she
wrote in The Chronicle of Higher
Education so it's out of control but you
know what do we do about it
I'm just hoping you know what I've done
and that's what this who questioned me
I'm not I'm not sure yeah I was gonna
ask you what's the importance of the me
to movement because obviously there's
been a lot of focus on hashtag me too
and people telling their stories and
again it seems like there's a lot of
conflation here where people say hashtag
me too about I was once catcalled on the
subway versus me too as in I was raped
by a male relative or something and it's
all supposed to be in the same category
and then anybody who suggests
differently is ripped up and down and I
remember which
after suggested recently that there were
that there are gradations to severity of
Matt Damon Matt Damon Matt Damon said
that he was being interviewed I think of
ABC News and he said he was he just
seemed very nice and he said he cared
about the movement and he liked a lot of
good men liberal and conservative they
are as horrified by it the Harvey
Weinstein stories as anyone and he was
like he says I care about that I want
the movement to succeed however there
are degrees of guilt and you know to
some proportion in terms of punishment
that's appropriate we he said you know
patting someone on the ass isn't the
same as rape and immediately his former
co-star Minnie Driver and this new this
angry woman thing you know angry woman
on Twitter she starts screeching you
know you you know there is a de what are
you saying it's all bad he didn't say
that it was good we just said there I
mean this is fundamental to our legal
and moral system that we make you know
judgments as serious unless here
she said she ruled it out of order and
then she said Matt Damon should just you
know basically told him to I can't STFU
and you know he should shut up and to me
this is gonna undo the movement because
I do think that we have to bring
relations between men and women up to
21st century standards in the workplace
there was you know too much going on and
making people unhappy but if something
men and women should do together not
make men the enemy you know it's good
women and bad men know it's human beings
improving the world together and that's
what Matt Damon was trying to do and
then he came out and said you know I'm
just I'm not gonna say anything I know
it's just time for me to listen and you
know if Matt Damon and he had to do that
I think because there was a petition and
30,000 me tours were trying to get him
erased from his next film or yeah I mean
the same thing happened or something
similar happen to Henry Cavill who just
suggested look in my personal life I'm a
famous guy and when I go out for a date
I have to worry about the fact that the
person sitting across from me knows I'm
rich and famous and so any false
accusation could ruin my career and cost
me millions of dollars so I'm more
likely to go out with an ex-girlfriend
who I at least know and trust then to
date a new woman and he just got
destroyed for it because how dare
you see just something so logical was
that right yeah you can't you men are
just you know they have to keep quiet
well that's not going to help and it's
it's it's actually going to ruin the
movement and now we have Weston him
asiya Argento you know he's got a
complicated story one of the things you
learn when you study this is and I
actually found it in this NYU case I
read his he's suing and I read his
complaint against avital Ronell and I
thought ah she's a monster this poor
point I felt so angry at her and
protective of him and then someone
published a letter that she wrote
explaining her side and then I read it
and thought hmm
gee maybe maybe maybe he's he's really
out of control and he's the crazy one
and you could see both sides and I owe
ya that's why we have trials if you're
accused of something serious it's so
I've learned that don't just go you
can't just believe people that's you
know courts of law show that people you
know maybe misrepresent reality and so
we have to sort it out so let's talk a
little bit about some of the problems
that women do face interviews we've
talked about the idea of the wage gap
being largely false the idea that
there's a giant rape culture being
largely false the the kind of
overblowing of the me to movement not
that women shouldn't come out everyone
agrees a woman who is abused in some way
should come forward and speak about we
should all be on her side when there's
evidence that this has happened but by
the same token the way that they're pro
it's being approached right now is
deeply flawed and undermining the
foundations of the movement what promise
do you see women generally facing in the
West or in the United States that you
think people aren't talking about enough
if any well the thing is that women's
problems are talked about a lot because
for good reason we had a women's
movement we have lots of organizations
everywhere and I actually see more
problems for men right now and men don't
have a lobby especially little boys and
I wrote a book the war against boys
what's happening with little boys in
school so right now I'm the mainly
concerned about the men and you know
that the vast numbers of men and
and the the boys that are dropping out
of school the men that have not just
dropped that aren't just unemployed
they're not looking for work we've got
you know able-bodied men in their prime
earning years who are not in the
workforce and we have an educational
system that is not meeting the needs of
men as well as women and and when I look
at women's problems because women do
have serious problems especially the
feminization of poverty if you are alone
with children it's very hard for women
and given the job as women do and so
it's they need men we need each other so
I don't really see it as separate at
this point I think we need kind of a an
egalitarian movement and that looks at
areas where we could help men because
when you help men you help women at this
point in the United States and and and
if you help women you help man
we need to we're in this together so the
problem of poverty the problem of single
motherhood and all that you've got us
they've got to be marriage able men
they've got to be guys and it's not
enough just to it used to be you could
graduate from high school and work hard
you could make it into the middle class
now you you almost required to have
college beyond high school
some specialization and far more women
are getting that than men so we may end
up closing the wage gap just by having a
better educated women but socially that
is not the projections are not good for
a stable society it's not good for the
workforce and other countries are
addressing that problem so anyway I do
see a problem the financial problem with
women but I think it's connected to men
the most serious problems for women
though as you said they're not in the
West I think they're many parts of the
world where they have not had two major
waves of feminism they haven't had so
much as a trickle and I go to
international women's conferences and I
meet women coming from you know Somalia
and Egypt and Iran which is a kind of
you know talk about a Handmaid's Tale I
mean that's like 1984 for women and in
many ways that although it's terrible
for men too but but I meet the women
that are that are sort of the freedom
fighters the the Elizabeth Cady Stanton
and Susan
Anthony and Sojourner Truth of those
countries and it's very exciting but
American women right now especially on
the campus who have so much to give and
who are so gifted and you know there you
are at Wellesley and you're at swath and
they're turned in on their own
oppression and not making common cause
with these women around the world that
didn't need help and they come to these
conferences they want help from American
women because we did liberate ourselves
and they want to do the same and I don't
understand why our women's movement
wouldn't be so focused on making those
connections and you know you go back in
the 80s on the college campus with our
part ID in South Africa and you know the
students were very focused on the social
justice in South Africa where are they
today on gender apartheid in in you know
Saudi Arabia or something they're mostly
talking about apartheid gender apartheid
in the Girl Scouts and Boy Scouts or you
know that we have separate you know the
language is all about in of crisis for
our society which is not a patriarchy no
to come back to the United States for a
second it seems to me one of the big
problems that I've seen particularly
among men since we're gonna talk about
men is this feeling of a lack of purpose
and that seems like that's been
exacerbated a lot by the false
perceptions regarding gender and sex
that my contention has always been that
young men particularly either create or
destroy and there's not a lot in between
and I can see it with my two and a half
year old boy he's a building blocks or
he's knocking them down those are the
only two things that he's doing at any
given time and usually he's knocking
them down usually he's just a suicide
machine he's trying to kill himself
full-time and it's my job to stop him
from doing that and a society that fails
to recognize that men actually have to
be thrust into positions of
responsibility including the
responsibility to protect women
shouldn't be all that surprised when it
turns out that men are destructive in
the absence of those responsibilities
well all societies who want to thrive
and survive have to spend and have spent
a lot of time civilizing their young
males yeah because if you don't do that
they have some very unpleasant ways of
making themselves noticed and if you
have a lot of sort of under socialized
young men
they they can develop and and there is a
I don't like to use the term anymore but
they say toxic masculinity I'll call it
protest masculinity and a young man
that's in that mode will show his
masculinity by destroying by tearing
down by preying on vulnerable people and
in fact it's just the opposite of
healthy masculinity healthy man who
admits a healthy masculinity they don't
destroy they build they create they
invent and they protect and in you know
societies everywhere men have largely
been the protectors and the Warriors and
you know defend from attack and and they
differ and there are a small number of
men who are the Predators and they did
they offend the society from them and we
put effort into that how do you get
these young men to develop a happy
healthy masculinity well helps to have a
father we don't hear that much about
fathers in fact you often hear that
denigrated in a you know oh that's just
an old-fashioned idea that children need
fathers well they do and we lovely boys
especially it seems to take an extra
toll they've looked at single-family
homes and the girls overall fare better
because first of all they have this
heroic mother who's working so hard they
pay and the boy finds his identity
elsewhere so you need the father and
then their ways through sports and
through athletics and so forth with a
coach and there are ways to focus that
energy and that you know creative into
healthy masculinity now overall we've
done a pretty good job I mean we don't
like to admit it but most people are not
out committing crimes and you know it's
all gone down we're doing something
right but we are what we're really
failing where I see we're failing most
seriously is engaging young men
academically and I see a lot of evidence
that our schools are increasingly they
favor people you know this the kids who
can who are happy to be sedentary and
you know talk about their feelings
there's a lot of lot of writing and
reading is about shared feelings and
and so a kid that comes in that likes
rough-and-tumble play and likes you know
can't sit still and takes it there it's
almost as if girls are the gold standard
and boys are being measured and they're
not so their first experience with
school is frustration and sometimes
failure much higher rates of boys
getting suspended and thrown out even in
preschool so people say I mean we don't
as I said before we don't have these
groups we don't have activist groups for
boys we have a lot for women and girls
and they've done good if it's done a lot
of good I mean we were faltering in math
and science and boy have we improved the
quality of math and science education
for girls where were the programs for
boys who are behind in reading all the
scores show I mean the boys score like
slightly better in math but a girl's
score higher in reading around the world
you need to put extra effort into
engaging a boy in the world of the
written word where is that in these
schools of Education where they're still
teaching I don't know you know radical
theories about women's oppression know
they're not learning it so there's a
whole field there's a lot of work to be
done I tell it when I go to schools yeah
there's a lot of work like male pedagogy
how to teach boys and they're already
starting in Australia and Canada because
they're worried about their workforce
they don't want to have you know 20 or
25 percent of it you know men you know
in some you know who can't cope in an
information economy so there we could
look at what the Australians and the
British are doing it but I don't know if
you tried to do it they'd say that's
backlash that's the patriarchy no it's
not I don't want to speak that language
anymore I don't think it's helpful
what's helpful is to recognize one
another men and women as as I said just
working together and mutual civility and
respect and even love this has been
known to happen so I have one final
question for Christina Hoff Sommers and
this question is a doozy I promise we're
gonna ask relationship advice from
christina hoff sommers but first you
have to be a daily wire subscriber
subscribe just go today
we're calm click Subscribe and you can
hear the end of our conversation over
there alright so check out the fem
Splinter's podcast also go and check out
the factual feminist over at American
Enterprise Institute Christina thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it thank you
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by micro Amina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah Oliveira entitled graphics
by Cynthia and Gullu ben shapiro shows
sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright board
Publishing 2018
[Music]